hey guys uh so the apple event just
ended i'm gonna be making a separate
video talking about all of the things
that they announced but i'm a very
special guest in this video his name is
tim cook hi
hello how are you i'm doing well how are
you really good good to see you again oh
my gosh youtube thanks so much for
joining this this fun little interview
here right after the event too so this
is amazing well thanks for having me so
how are you feeling fresh off the stage
the virtual stage i'm feeling great i
always get so excited on days like this
for launch day and uh today was just
just off the charts i mean you get
excited but obviously we all do too and
one of the things that i love so much is
actually getting to go to those
in-person events and those were so much
fun but the way that you guys have made
these virtual events kind of let
everyone experience that magic that we
felt actually being at apple campus is
so incredible it's like what has it been
like for you guys
creating this all new way of launching
products it you know it's so great to
get such a positive response from people
and it's it's great to invite people
here so that they can get a glimpse of
what it looks like inside and sort of
pull back the curtain a bit
on apple park i'm just so happy with the
with the response that we've gotten and
and how many more people we're able to
to show our place to and invite them
into our home it's so beautiful and even
all those fly-throughs of california
like i live here and it was just so
awesome to sort of experience that it
was amazing yeah it's it's you know it's
great to show places that really inspire
you to think in perhaps that they'll
inspire other people as well and we
really did that uh across the board
today you guys really did and one of the
things obviously being such a huge apple
fan basically all of my life this is so
awesome to get a chance to chat with you
and usually there's always like one
thing that's like super surprising and
for me this event was actually the ipad
mini the ipad mini i like i love the
ipad mini and i know so many of my
friends do and i have a lot of friends
like in the medical field that they use
them and i think what really impressed
me was like the huge upgrade that it got
so how do you kind of see this mini kind
of fitting into the whole ipad lineup
well you know it's our biggest upgrade
ever for ipad mini it's it is huge as
you said and people use it in so many
different ways we wanted to appeal to
all of these type of usages people
really love the power of having this
incredible device in the palm of their
hand having the full ipad experience you
know not a part of an ipad what we see
is people are using it in the classroom
they're using it in hospitals they're
using it to capture uh photos to capture
video it's it's amazing all the use
cases of it which is when you have
something so
uh ultra portable like this it's
incredible where it goes i just happen
to have one here
oh this is this is such a treat oh it's
unbelievable it's really unbelievable
look at that
it's great and with 5g capabilities
you can take this everywhere i sort of
was joking on twitter i tweeted i was
like i think i'm moving my entire
business and all of my workflow to the
ipad mini but it's wild because like i
actually think i could
yeah that's that's the that's the thing
that is so jaw-dropping about it is that
you could put so much performance in a
form factor like that like this it's
it's really incredible i think everybody
that is an ipad mini fan is is really
going to have their day with would get
it getting one of these yeah even you
might have some new ipad mini users i
think yeah yeah i suspect you're right i
am of course a huge iphone fan too and
you guys announced a lot of stuff here
with the iphone 13 and one of the things
that for me as a creator that got me so
excited is this new camera system so how
do you see the whole iphone 13 lineup
kind of changing the way that people
create content you know things like
cinematic mode this is like having a
hollywood rig in your pocket it's
mind-blowing the iphone 13 pro with
three incredible new cameras the best
dual camera system ever on the iphone 13
you're absolutely right there's just
there's so much here yeah what's great
too is i'm so glad that you guys uh
released a pink iphone because
i was gonna be here i was like that was
my number one question i was like tim
can we please get a pink iphone and you
guys did it so you're off the hook now i
saw your tweet i saw your tweet i'm so
glad that you're happy with it yes and i
you know i think that's the thing that's
so fun is you guys have all these really
great colors too so it's like you really
can kind of express yourself not only
creatively by creating content but you
can choose whichever color you like too
you absolutely can and all the colors
are incredible they even look better in
person the new sierra blue
big fan yeah totally compliment that
that pink iphone 13. this is the one
that i'm using that's awesome yeah so
another thing obviously uh a huge apple
watch fan i think ever since the
beginning of i guess when the first
apple watch came out like for me
personally like it really changed the
way that i kind of worked out the way
that i sort of quantified my fitness and
even had like competitions with friends
like is the apple watch changed kind of
the way that you approach fitness or
kind of changed from your daily
activities that you normally would do
you know i can't imagine doing a workout
now without the apple watch pretty
amazing to me of what i used to think i
did versus what i really do
and you know the watch sort of motivated
me to to begin to do what i thought i
was doing before but i wasn't really
doing it it's so great to get notes and
so forth from customers where it's
really changed their life in a in a
material way
they're more healthy and and more fit
you know fitness plus has been out for a
little under a year and it's just
amazing the the idea of democratizing
sort of the world's best trainers and
inviting them into your home coming to
where you are are on the go now we've
added more workouts with pilates and ski
workouts and uh one that i'm going to be
doing is meditation we're really happy
to to bring all of these things to our
customers fitness plus was something
that i was really excited when you guys
announced this because i do a ton of
workouts from home on you know various
digital platforms and what i loved so
much about it was a lot of these classes
that i've done on other platforms i feel
like sometimes my time was wasted and i
feel like there is never a class that i
have done on apple fitness where i feel
like i didn't get a good workout or it
was engaging and fun so whatever you
guys are doing over there congrats and
it's honestly so great you know it's r
it's all about the people that we have
in fitness plus the trainers are
unbelievable and the integration with
apple watch is just amazing in terms of
keeping you motivated through the
workout and uh helping you achieve your
fitness goals yeah it's so fun do you
have any favorite kind of like fitness
workouts that you usually like to do you
know i
i've i've made a rule of not having any
favorites
but that's the thing i've actually been
inspired by going through and i'm like i
think i'm going to try some tai chi now
like why not it's an apple fitness yeah
option so let's do it you also announced
some of the additional bike features
this fall detection is a huge deal i get
several notes uh you know daily about
people that fall detection has been
activated on and so now bringing that
into terms of more cases more use cases
is going to be really a big deal no it's
really cool and oh another thing too the
group fitness classes yes so before
doing group fitness classes was such a
way for me to get motivated so this is
such a cool integration and i'm really
hoping that i can get like 32 of my tech
youtuber friends to agree to doing a
group fitness class you know there's
nothing like joining with your peers to
do fitness because it pushes you to do
more than you would do normally and uh
so that that's what fitness plus is all
about is you know helping you get the
most out of your workout yeah and it's
just like everything just integrates so
well with the apple ecosystem and just
being able to kind of get those
notifications directly on like apple tv
yeah and you know i love the digital
badges that you can earn you know there
was one for uh national parks uh
recently you may have taken that
yeah yeah i i love getting these and you
know even if i have not planned to work
out for the day and one of those things
come up i have to go work out it really
shows that it really shows that they
were no it's super motivating too
because you're actually able to look and
see
the progress of your fitness so during
the pandemic i never thought i was a
runner i started running just because it
was something new and fun and the apple
watch honestly was that main motivator
because you actually could see the heart
rate data and you could see the
progression and i think that's so
inspiring for so many people you know we
didn't plan it like this but fitness
plus showed up at exactly the right time
for people because of the pandemic and
enabled them to go sample a lot of
different kind of workouts for their
home gotten
quite a bit of feedback about that also
what i love is i feel like it's not too
advanced like there's classes for
everyone so it's like my grandmother can
work out i can work out and everybody in
between so i feel like you're really
kind of including everyone in that yeah
it doesn't matter if you're a beginner
or you're advanced you can find
something on there that is for you also
going into ar so i'm such a huge fan of
augmented reality and i know you guys
didn't talk much about it here but with
lidar and so many of these devices what
kind of like big picture scenario do you
see this kind of fitting into people's
lives in the future you know i i am so
excited about ar i think ar is one of
these very few profound technologies
that we will look back on one day and
went
how did we live our lives without it and
so right now you can experience and
experience it in thousands of ways using
your ipad or your iphone but of course
those will get better and better over
over time already it's a great way to
shop it's a great way to learn it
enhances the learning process i can't
wait for it to be even more important in
collaboration and and and so forth so i
am a i'm ar fan number one uh i think
it's that big okay then i must be number
two
but i just think like the future of that
like i always have so many big ideas
that i feel like it's gonna really
change the way that content creators
create and consumers kind of enjoy that
content yeah i i i agree i mean you know
you know simple things today that you
can use it for like if you're shopping
for
a sofa or a chair or a lamp
in terms of really experiencing it in
your place we've never been able to do
that before until until the last couple
years or so and and that's at the early
innings of ar
it it's it will it will only get better
i'm very excited so one last thing so
everyone knows that i'm a huge fan of
apple stores i love the experience just
like from shopping to the today apple
classes and i also saw you there at the
downtown los angeles store opening it
was the last time we saw each other yes
it was so amazing that was so fun and
that store is just so beautiful but how
do you see this store and many others
kind of reviving parts of cities and
giving back to communities yeah you know
that story in particular uh
it's so
incredible to be in a position to give
back to the the city and get back to the
community there and this old theater as
you saw the before picture that you
probably saw in the after picture are
totally totally different we restored it
we preserved it it's an important part
of history in downtown l.a the first
motion picture theater with audio it's a
very important kind of place and it had
been left just untouched for decades so
it's great to be able to restore it and
now to be able to have today at apple
sessions and creative studios in the
store and to be able to connect
underrepresented communities directly
with mentors and creatives in the
community so that they can mentor their
creative uh career and so forth this is
this is really big it really makes it
really warms my heart me too and that's
why i was so excited just to see
it bringing life back into downtown and
yeah getting that foot traffic and
getting people out and just really
enjoying the technology and obviously
huge fan of apple store so it was so
good to see you there and
congratulations on the launch
congratulations on a successful event
today thank you of course you know i
will be uh we can maybe facetime later
on the new iphone 13s when they come out
i will look forward to it i'm already
using mine
oh my gosh i will definitely also send
you a group invite to our fitness plus
classes no pressure okay the invite is
open i'll look forward to it thank you
so much yeah thank you for having me on
your program i appreciate it bye
[Music]
so thank you guys for watching and tim
thank you so much for joining me here on
my youtube channel this was so much fun
i have been a huge apple fan my entire
life and one of the reasons that i've
loved apple so much is it was the first
device when i was very young that i
found that let me express myself that
allowed me to create in ways that i
never thought were possible and ever
since i was a little kid i've carried
that through to today so to be able to
chat with tim who has been such a huge
part of apple and has really kind of
almost shaped our entire generation was
really incredible and also something
that is kind of personal to me is apple
stores i love the apple store experience
so much jenna just texted me to tell tim
that she said hi she's like 20 minutes
late but tim my sister says hi
[Laughter]
you're too late you're too late jenna
anyway i could talk about this forever
but i'm just so thankful and grateful
for all of you guys who watch my videos
and who support creators because you
really do allow us to live our dreams
and be able to just keep creating
content and
it's just honestly so fun and i might
start crying so i'm just gonna end this
video right now i'll see you guys in the
next one make sure you subscribe
bye subscribe for tears
[Music]
you